hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to when
you go into a video store what's the
very first thing you see besides a
pretentious teenager wants to tell you
what is crappy best big section covers
tons and tons of DVD covers some of them
grab your attention others you're glad
they don't crave your attention but some
are actually hand-painted and
practically suck you into the movie
before you even see it would you believe
that most of these incredible
hand-painted iconic posters like Back to
the Future in the ad Jones and Harry
Potter were all done by the same person
that is the work of great illustrator
and artist Drew Struzan now unlike the
nostalgia critic Drew Struzan is not a
household name but he should be this guy
is responsible for getting audiences
into those movie seats now I know you
can probably say the trailers for movies
were more responsible for that but the
posters but here's the thing trailers
back then weren't like trailers today
like here's a trailer for an older
from Steven Spielberg and George Lucas
Indiana Jones not very exciting but when
you look at the poster holy shit this
looks friggin epic look at the layout
look the expressions look at how he
captures the size and scope of the
entire movie just on a blank sheet of
paper if anything you can make the
argument that trailers have tried harder
to be more like Susan's pollsters than
its throughs on posters like the
trailers nowadays every trailer looks
intense epic and exciting the troupe's
posters have always ended even from the
beginning that is when he started doing
posters he first started out doing album
designs most notably black 7 VG's and
Alice Cooper is welcome to the nightmare
he started to move into doing a movie
pulses but none of them were really epic
enough to make it stand out for bids it
wasn't until a certain theme movie named
Star Wars came out that drew start
getting real recognition for since then
Drew has done it ton of iconic movies
including the bags of future films the
Muppet movie zinnia Jones movies and of
course the starlet so what is it about
true this work that makes it stand out
so much what is it that just makes the
images seem to leap off the poster I
mean for God's sakes follow that bird
looks like a friggin epic a lot of it is
that captures the essence of the movie
always making it exciting and fitting as
much as he can into one buoyant sheet
you look at all the characters the
throwing images and you shout out dude I
gotta know what the hell this movie is
about through the seventies eighties and
even a little bit of the 90s Drew
Struzan was the guy to go to for your
movie poster needs but from the mid 90s
on digital technology was reigning
supreme and the idea of paying someone
to paint a picture when they could just
Photoshop it together didn't seem
cost-effective
because of this will be posters at
suffer big time just posting celebrity
faces together sucking out all the epic
quality when we looked at his true sound
poster he kept the idea he was telling a
story and he wanted to share that story
with you when you look at a poster today
all you see is an ad a marketing told I
want you to just buy tickets now granted
that is what a poster is supposed to do
but it's also supposed to disguise that
fact and many posters trestles seem to
do that anymore
like look at the Shrek poster all
they're doing is sitting there we and
how many times have we seen just one
egotistical face take up the entire
poster by Tom Cruise Nicolas Cage or
Julia Roberts these posters don't tell
us what the movies about they don't even
give us a reason to see the film outside
the fact that they have a celebrity who
obviously got Top Billing but thankfully
drew isn't out when the Star Wars
prequels came out they commissioned him
to do every single one of the new
posters probably the only thing that
actually seemed reminiscent of the
original Star Wars films and when
another unnecessary Lucas sequel was
released guess who they got to do the
posters good old truth even some films
like the Hellboy movies hand were
commissioned from it but we're never
used look at these posters here's the
one that drew painted up and here's the
one that they ultimately went with what
olodum for the few movie posters
nowadays that do suck you and all I have
to give thanks to the master himself
borrowing much of their layout technique
from this big scale artist today drew
does when he's always bitching painting
he's done album covers novels comic
boats ads and a whole slew of
illustrations who considers himself a
true introvert doing very few interviews
and spending most of this time on his
art work in fact when I personally asked
it
nostalgia critic II very politely
declined which is interesting after I
heard this from a rare radio interview
he did I was just riding a guy that
wants to do an interview for his website
and I just told them you know the old
saying better to keep your mouth shut
and be thought a fool than to open your
mouth and remove all doubt yeah that was
me I was the asshole want to do the
interview it's an honor to be blown up
by you sir but status as obnoxious
pestering monkey is well assured for all
the joking juice juice that really is a
great artist defining a whole generation
of movies simply with his paintbrush and
a blank canvas when asked about whether
or not he'd succumb to the pressures of
digital technology and do more computer
work true son had this to say I love the
texture of paint made of colored earth
of oil from the trees and of canvas and
paper I love the expression of paint
from a brush or a hand smearing charcoal
the dripping of paint and moisture of
water the smell of the materials i
delighted the changeable nature of
opinion with the morning light or in the
afternoon when the Sun turns of painting
orange or by firelight at night the
paint is part of the expression juice
cruising really is a part of movie
history and very few people even know
his name
his artwork was colorful grand stylish
clever and half the time even better
than the actual movie if we would've
judge a book by its cover then every
single movie juice juice on has worked
on with the epic masterpiece I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to